so rivers e benvenuti l'uno vissi movida
se siete nuovi benvenuti nel canale a
proposito di canale ci stiamo
avvicinando al milione quindi agazzi
dati una mano anche voi se non vi siete
ancora iscritti iscrivetevi subito sì sì
ho fatto alcuni danni ultimamente
ma andiamo per step iniziamo dai saldi
c'è veramente un decimo del video
partiamo da zara con i saldi ho comprato
molto poco da zona
ho preso questo e non l'ho ancora messo
per ovvie ragioni non lo so mi piaceva
però effettivamente non è che proprio
emettere banner far la spesa sempre con
i saldi e sempre della serie nella
sommarietà prima di tutto
pantalone leopardato la società prima di
tutto viva le trasparenze non ancora
capito bene cosa ci metterò sotto
sicuramente ho un body color carne o un
reggiseno carne o bianco non lo so da
valutare però mi piaceva indovinate un
po
i saldi sono finiti tutto il resto è
nuova collezione direttamente dalla
moquette di casa della nonna
sempre da zero ho trovato lui non l'ho
ancora provato non provo e vestiti la
maggiore a tre volte non proprio dei
siti negozi perché troppa con e camerini
non ho voglia di svestire adesso inverno
san pietro
quindi dico li provo a casa al massimo
poi li cambio quindi non l'ho ancora
provato però mi ispira perché è stretto
dalla vita in giù ma verso il seno si
allarga le maniche sono un pò larghe vi
farò sapere
lo passi oro bondi poi stiamo entrando
un po in modalità sobrio pantalone che
anche questo devo ancora provare provare
sempre di zara
io ho un problema che va ad analizzare
perché spesso li xs che era mia taglia
vista larga quindi questo qua lo proverò
capirò se lo bombolo passo rosa
sigaretta di tal da con una bella
camicetta dentro una décolleté e si vola
pronta per piccole donne con questa
camicia over size questo patetico
colletto con delle
con dei fili di perle che insomma ben il
pendolo dal colletto finiamo gli
acquisti da zara con una fantastica
anche questa camicia con i bottoni i
dettagli oro over size di ecopelle
ovviamente che me la sono subito
immaginata o con un vestito molto
aderente magari anche un tubino nero e
questa aperta così magari anche un po
abbassata lariana grande della serie
cielo ma non ce l'ho oppure niente per
la sono immaginata così o così o niente
non la dà verso i sorpreso solo un
maglione è un negozio che mi piace ma
appunto non trovo spesso cose nel mio
stile
quindi è uno di quelli
in cui guardo tutto ma mi attira poca
roba
lui mi attirava perché perché facciamo
molto taylor swift che suona con la
chitarra in un locale delle campagne del
texas
passiamo da h m o e cene ho preso questa
gonna verde militare perché mi ricordava
tantissimo la gonna che metteva alle
medie era praticamente uguale ma invece
di esser a vita alta come va adesso era
un po più a vita bassa da camera un
trionfo di verde militare e robe
mimetiche tant'è che mi sono fatta
convincere sono commenta da sola a
prendere anche questa t shirt
non so quanto la userò ma mi sembrava
molto in poi ho preso questa felpa
che è molto finiamo in bellezza con un
bel vestito mimetico aderente
lo so che da tutto il video che
ovviamente puntate questi sacchetti
lasciati per il finale per un motivo
andiamo con ordine sapete che adoro
mouse e ho preso questo cappotto che
volevo da una vita modello io lo
chiamano si chiama così accappatoio
perché accappatoio perché appunto
sembrano quindi cintura in vita e si va
a comandare
l'ho preso perchè mi sono immaginato un
attimo in modalità sarah jessica parker
in sex and the city
io che scendo a prendere un caffè da
starbucks così con la prima cosa che
trovo quindi sotto in pigiama pigiama di
seta sopra il questo cappotto po chiuso
così velocemente per andare a prendere
il caffè perché senza caffè non può
partire la mia giornata
passiamo a jimmy choo questo è il mio
primo paio di scarpe della vita knox mio
paio di jimmy choo rimandato in giro
scalzo mio primo paio di jimmy choo è di
avviso già è proprio basic nel senso
la roba più classica del mondo però
avevo bisogno di queste forgery scarpa
che volevo fosse una scarpa di qualità
che vi durasse e resistente buone a
comfort delle normalissime décolleté
nere di vernice tacco 10 perché sono
molto comodi le voglio usare magari per
gli eventi cosa in cui giornate e serate
volevo stare in piedi tanto quindi
volevo la comodità piani tutto nere
perché ovviamente una décolleté nera non
può mai mancare nella strategia di una
donna della mia età è mancata fino
adesso non so come ho fatto a vivere ci
avvicinarsi siamo arrivati al due
bambine ma mille piccole devo dire ma
meravigliosa da quelle partiamo cui cui
lo si capisce neanche cosa perché girato
quindi decisione difficile partiamo da
lei da lui lei non ha sesso
allora volevo un marsupio di gucci da
tantissimo tempo avevo adocchiato quelli
di velluto ma trovano il tempo che
trovano nel senso che dura ci puoi
mettere santo durante l'inverno non è
che a maggio oa giugno tu mi va in giro
con il borsone di velluto almeno io non
mi sento di metterlo magari si può
mettere non sono queste la mia opinione
quindi avevo accantonato questa idea
però l'idea del marsupio di una cosa
comoda ma anche chic mi gironzolava da
un po in testa poi
ho visto
lui ed è stato colpo di fulmine
ma bando alle ciance vi faccio vedere
subito si è capito top ma non è finita
qui perché se non lo volete mettere il
vita lo potete mettere può anche essere
messo così però scusami eh se io metto
dentro volendo una volta vuole usare la
persona ma dai ma ragazzi ma di cosa
parliamo
metto dentro le catene così quindi tutti
e due avevo ragione io è un ibrido con
gender fluid poi entrò in un altro
negozio uno dei miei preferiti di borse
e accessori e penso ma scusate io
scusate scusa che parlavo come sessums
la procederà a cielo ma su piacerò lo
zainetto di moschino cielo la borsa
tutti i giorni cielo però che cos'è che
è che ogni volta che esco che
un'occasione speciale mi manca o no un
attimo girato lo sguardo e ho visto lei
che vi faceva così
io tipo occhi a cuore
quasi come la prada e vi giuro che anche
qui c'è stata una mezza scena con una
cinese che l'aveva adocchiata cioè io so
che problemi abbia abbandonato ce la
faccio vedere quante meravigliosa è una
di quelle borse che tu puoi usare in
qualsiasi occasione
jeans giacca di pelle primavera un po
scollata comunque casual
tu dici che cosa ci aggiungo per perché
questo look sia casual chic top of the
pops play evento di gala vestito
elegante lungo scarpa news
cosa manca bikini in spiaggia infradito
cosa ti manca ma barberi scherzi è una
borsa puoi mettere in molte occasioni ma
soprattutto è bellissima poi ovviamente
c'è sempre loro ho tradito loro nero
questo è un mio tenero new d'oro tesoro
si può mettere sia a tracolla che così
via
e niente io sono follemente innamorata
con la mia nuova bambina abbiamo
terminato il video all
spero tantissimo che vi sia piaciuto
fatemi sapere qui sotto
che cosa avete preferito o meglio perché
io conosco
noi donne quale tra le due borse avete
preferito che una donna guarda questo
video vede solo le borse restano quindi
fatemi sapere quale dei due acquisti top
100 rana avete preferito
vi mando un bacione e ci vediamo al
prossimo video mi raccomando se avete
fatto iscrivetevi al canale e seguitemi
su instagram e tic toc per vedere le
foto di questi outfit di questi
accessori indossati
ciao adoro
[Musica]